Hey everyone, it's Mike from Orderflows,
and I'm shooting this quick video
because, you know, I want to answer this
question that I I tend to get. It's sort
of a recurring question. It's why should
I add order flow analysis to my trading?
And the way I like to describe it is,
you know, order flow is a tool. Okay?
It's not a red light, green light
trading system as some people have you
believe. And, you know, and as a tool,
it's going to help you as a trader. Now,
think of it like a doctor. Um you know,
a doctor has tools and he uses tools to
diagnose the condition of a patient.
And, you know, once a doctor understands
the condition of the patient, then he
knows how to proceed treating him. And
it's the same way. You know, you use the
order flow tools to diagnose the
condition of the market. And once you
diagnose the market, then you're going
to know how to approach the market. And,
you know, one thing to keep in mind, you
know, conditions in the market, you
know, they change constantly. You know,
supply and demand, you know, the whole
reason for the markets existing are
always battling against each other. And
change is inevitable. So, it's going to
be important to be able to have tools
that are going to identify when change
is occurring. And when this change often
occurs is is when you get market moves.
Now, before I begin,
let me just go over a brief disclaimer.
Um this presentation is for educational
and informational purposes only. Should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision.
Futures trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor. An
investor potentially lose all or more
than the initial investment. Risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle. Only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. Past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results. All right.
So, you know, one of the tools that uh
we developed and released in our
Orderflows Trader 2.0, which is
available for NinjaTrader 7 and 8. Um we
recently went back and reprogrammed
NinjaTrader 7 to add it in there. It
wasn't it wasn't in there before
because, you know, we were doing our
developments on NinjaTrader 8. But, you
know, there was there was people asking
for NinjaTrader that you know, there's
they're stuck uh stuck on NinjaTrader 7
because they got a ton of indicators
that haven't been ported over to
NinjaTrader 8. And so, that's why we
went back and and added it into uh
NinjaTrader 7.
So,
you know, if you're in that boat, we got
you covered. But, you know, one of the
things that we added in there was was
our prominent point of control tool. And
what it is, it's a combination of price
action
um and order flow analysis. And what it
does is it looks for areas uh point of
controls specifically that uh act as
support or resistance, you know, based
on I said like the combination price
action and order flow. And it will
highlight it uh aqua. Well,
my settings are aqua and then for buy or
for support, rather, and magenta for
resistance um for areas to get short.
And you can see here, I mean, this is
just this morning here in the crude oil
uh around 7:50, just before 8:00, you
know, you you came into the swing low
um 69.95.
You got a prominent point of control.
Market rallies up here to, you know, to
30s, almost up to 40. Comes off of it.
You hit another prominent point of
control. Market uh rallies back up
again. Um this is another indicator we
added in here. This is the multiple
imbalances.
Um then it came up here, you know, from
this prominent point of control. Rallied
up here to
another prominent point of control and
it gave a nice sell signal from, you
know, the 7040 area all the way down,
you know, back down to the 7010 area.
Now,
it's uh
it's it's you know, it's interesting
because
you know,
sometimes, you know, people are always
trying to predict the market. Well, tell
me where the market's going. Well,
you know, order flow is not going to
help you predict the market. It's going
to tell you what's happening in the
market right now so you can make, you
know, the best possible decision based
on what's happening right now. You know,
you got to trade in the present. You're
not trading in the future. You don't
have a a time machine that uh you know,
you go into the future then come back
and say, "Oh, yeah, see, it predicted it
there." But, um
you know, let me just uh take a look
here at a
Where is I had an eight range chart in
the minis and it disappeared here.
Um here they are. E-minis. Um again,
this is this morning here. You know,
right up here at the high,
you know, you had a divergence. You had
the prominent point of control, which
is, you know, is is a setup that I talk
about a lot um you know, to users of my
software. You know, look for look for
these setups. And you can see how it
sells off right from the high. Now,
again, I'm not trying to predict the
high. I'm letting the market tell me,
"Hey, a high is being made here." And
then we're selling off from, you know,
the 28 19 28 20 area all the way down
to, you know, down to the 13-ish area.
Um you ran into some
support down here. You pop up to an area
right where you had
some resistance from earlier with
prominent point of control. Then you
came right back down, breaking through
this resistance. You got a strong um
selling imbalance, stack selling
imbalance. But, then you got another
support area down here. You got your
prominent point of control. You got a
bullish ratio. And notice how the market
is starting to rally back up. Now,
you know, it's it's interesting because
um
like like for example, this is Nasdaq. I
haven't looked at the Nasdaq. Nasdaq
again some very good moves in here. This
is a one minute chart, by the way, on
the Nasdaq. Um yeah, nothing today. But,
I'll just show you, you know, like la-
last week uh I don't remember what day.
Let's go through here.
Um
you know, it was just picking some
doozies. I don't think it was this day.
I think it was the day before that. Um
like like every major major move. Now,
again, you know,
nothing is going to predict the market
or, you know, give you accurate uh
diagnosis, you know, if that's the term,
100% of the time. You know, you you'd
like 100% accuracy, but, you know, what?
There's there's just so much going on in
the markets at any given moment that you
know, especially now with with President
Trump, um you know, it's it's hard to
I I really the the news cycles, you
know, something comes out and then
you know, the day later, you're not
talking about it. You're talking about
something else. And and the markets are
are the same way. But, um
let me just find the day. I I apologize
here. But, uh
I forgot what day it was.
You know, I'm not I'm not trying to
cherry-pick it, but I mean, it's it's
just one of those things where it's
just, you know, super uncanny. You know,
like this I forgot I don't know what day
this is. But, um I think this was
Wednesday. You know, you got a support
point of control here. You know, market
rallies up to a resistant point of
control there. Sells off this one. Yeah,
you get a little rally over the next bar
to um you know, these
you rally right back. Where do you rally
back up to? You rally You have your
prominent point of control here. You
rally back up right to that level. Sell
off. Then you boom, you get another
prominent point of control. What
happens? The market puts in a nice
rally. Um this one doesn't work. This
one fails.
This one, what do you do? You rally
right back up to that area. You sell off
again. Um this one fails.
Um then you get this nice beautiful one,
divergence and your prominent point of
control.
Yeah, you're trading 7483,
7482.
And, you know, you sell off down into
the 7470s.
Down in here, you rally back up. Um
I wouldn't think this was the day. But,
uh
yeah, it it just it it's it happens
when this was the day that the Facebook
got slapped here. That's where you got
that one big bar down here from 7525
down to 7480. That's um what day was
that that Facebook got spanked on uh
I think it was Wednesday.
You know, even in the after hours.
Again, I'm not a big advocate of trading
Nasdaq in the after hours. But, you
know, when you have some big news coming
out like that, you know, you tend to get
a lot of movement in the after hours.
This was the day after This was the
reopen after the Facebook thing. You got
your divergence. You got your prominent
point of control. And look, 7426. It's
just gets spanked all the way down down
down down to, you know, the the mid
7400s.
Um
But, it it's it's one of those things
where you know, you
you need tools. I mean, you know, you
can Can you do this analysis yourself?
Yeah, probably, you know, if you know
what to look for. But, I'll be honest,
you know, most people don't know what to
look for when they're looking at order
flow. And, you know, there's a lot of
quote order flow tools out there. And
honestly, a lot of them are very very
confusing. You know, I I look at them
and they confuse the heck out of me.
And, you know, and I understand order
flow pretty good, I like to think. But,
um I I see some of these tools and it's
just like there's so many extra numbers.
You know, it's one thing you're dealing
with, you know, volume footprint chart
with a lot of numbers. But, then they
start adding, you know, you got like
some of them, you know, bars got like
five different numbers on top and
another five below it. And honestly, it
just confuses confuses me the more
you know,
it's not one of these things, you know,
the more you throw at the wall and
hope something sticks. You know,
basically what you're doing with that
is, you know, is is you're taking the
whole concept from, you know, indicator
trading is like you know, the more
indicators you have on your your chart,
you know,
the better trader you're going to be.
No, it's not like that. You know, it's
not like the more numbers you got
floating around on your chart, the um
better trader you're going to be.
No, it's, you know, having effective
tools on your chart is going to help you
as a trader.
And, you know, that's why we developed
these tools is to is to help traders,
you know, help traders make better
decisions.
So, you know, hopefully by now you can
see how, you know, this this tools that
we developed are, you know, are pretty
good. You know, like you know, here this
on on the next day, you know, you sort
of ran into the you know, resistance
into support, you know, earlier ran into
resistance into support a couple of
times as well. Um
This is where the cash close. That's why
you, You know, the cash close on on
stock indices that that's where the most
volume of the day is going to be
generally. Um you know, everyone's
trying to peg their, you know, all the
funds are are trying to peg their um
portfolio to, you know, to the close
um of equities.
But um you know,
it's just uncanny, you know, like here,
you know, boom 7:30
you get this nice buy signal. I mean,
look at this how it just rallies up
there. Again, you know, not every signal
is going to be perfect like textbook
example like this. You know, you're
going to get some that
you know, a bar or two later, you know,
you get stopped out.
You know, like this you know, this bar
right on the cash open. Look at this.
8:30
you know, it came right back up here.
You know, market here you probably put a
control. You know, you got some
resistance up here. You sell off.
Next bar opens up. You sell.
You going back and forth. You rally back
up, but you know, you got a resistance
level up here. You know, if you were
smart, you going to throw in an offer up
around here
with a stop, you know, just behind it,
you know, up here a little higher. And
look at that you could have caught this
move, you know, and on Nasdaq is not one
where you could have a very tight stop
because it's extremely volatile. It just
jumps all over the place. But
you know, look at that. You know, 74
Even if you just caught this one bar,
you know, I'm not talking about catch
the rest of the bars following it. If
you just caught this one bar here, um
you know, you you short around 55.
You know, and then you you cover in the
next bar at 50. That's five full points.
But look at that move. Now, that was a
nice and dramatic move.
You know, and it's not something that
occurs,
you know, every other bar or um you
know, sometimes you get a couple of
signals a day which you know, as as a
trader you mean you don't necessarily
want to be over trading and and taking
so many trades, you know, that that
that's one of the problems that, you
know, sometimes traders faces they're I
don't say over trading, but they're
taking a lot of signals because you
know, they they need action cuz they
don't have necessarily a proper trading
plan. And then they they end up giving
back a a lot of their profits. Um again,
you know, here yeah, you rally back. You
know, if if you got short in this bar
and and you didn't cover it down here,
you know, five points later, you know,
market did stop you out before going
back down. You know, it's just where do
you place your stop? I mean, you know,
it depends on you and then and your
trading plan. You know, how much risk
you want to take per trade. Um you know,
some people have have a wider risks and
and some people don't.
And this is the
PM session here the
29th which was Friday.
This is fast forwarded to the day
session.
You know,
I don't usually like to trade around you
know, the 7:30 time. That's when you get
a lot of numbers being released. And you
know, honestly for Nasdaq it's it's
something you should stick to around the
cash hours preferably. Um you know,
after the numbers at 7:30, you know, so
eight. But then you know, obviously
there's a big difference once the cash
opens and you can see all the volume
just jumps, you know, here prior to cash
you're trading us on minute base chart.
You're trading 100, you know, maybe some
bars got a couple hundred, 300, 400. But
after cash opens, you know, you're
trading in the thousands, 2,000, 2,000,
2,000
and so on.
And you can see, you know, some of these
bars you know, they're they're you get
big movements, right? With on one minute
chart, you know, from 7210 all the way
up to 7220.
Uh so that takes us to today. So this
morning on nothing in in the Nasdaq
showing. Now, you know, just really
quick here in in the bonds
um
you know, just this morning, you know,
here you had your ratio I should say
your ratio divergence and you know,
it sold off a little bit. Um came down
to a support area. Rallied back up to a
resistance area. Came down into the
support. Um you came down in here to a
support area. You got a nice little move
up. Came off a couple ticks here. You
got your
supportive buying going on right there.
Um
Let's take a look at uh bonds.
You know, similar thing
in the bonds it's just going back and
forth like that.
You know, here this morning 3:00 it you
have this
swing high here, prominent point of
control 16244.
Where does it rally back up to? Notice
where does it rally back up to? It
rallies back up to
um 44 each time once, twice before
selling off to the lows at 24.
You know, here's your divergence and
your prominent point of control. You
know, you rally from
um 26 27 all the way up to 36 37 where
you got another prominent point of
control. So
you know, again it's not about trying to
predict the it's not about trying to
find hot predict highs or lows, but
rather you can find the highs or lows
when the market is telling you, "Hey,
you know, what? You know, based on the
order flow
um we're putting in a low or we're
putting in a high."
So you know, that's that's how you use
the tools of of order flow.
Um you know, some people say, "Well, you
don't teach anything on these videos."
Well, these videos are created for the
users of my software
um you know, so they can better
understand how to use it. You know, if
you don't have my software, you know,
maybe this video is isn't doesn't
provide you much value, but
um you know, hopefully you know, you'll
get some value out of it.
You know, look at this. You know, here
you got your divergence. This is right
after the open.
Um your divergence, your prominent point
of control, you sell off. Um again from
the 46 area all the way down to the 26
area. You rally up
from prominent point of control to
another prominent point of control and
you sell off again.
Um
you know, I mean that's why I talk about
having
easy to use set of tools. You know, I've
seen literally I see some people's um
order flow
quote tools that they use and it's
literally like they're throwing
everything the kitchen sink at you. Um
basically trying to give you 10
different things to look at that when
one of them is right, they'll say,
"Well, you see I I you know, if you
looked at that indicator." You know, I
could put like five different numbers up
here and one of them will be right and I
you know, then say, "Well, see that
number was right." Well, what's the
whole point of it? It's like when you
know, when I was when I was younger I
used to go to the racetrack um and you
know, there'd be sell the guys out there
selling tip sheets. Okay? And they'd
give you like
three or four or five horses in each
race and then
you know, there's only like eight or
nine horses in in a race and when one of
them wins, you know, the next day
they'll they'll have their sheet from
yesterday out there with all the winners
circled. Well, if you're giving me, you
know,
60% of the horses per race on your tip
sheet,
you you I expect you to have a very high
winning percentage because you could you
got five horses to choose from. And you
know, it's sort of
misleading in the sense that you know,
you got a tip sheet with with uh you
know, listing five horses per race and
then the next day you come out and say,
"Well, you see I had the winner of the
race." Well, you also had four losers in
the race. And you know, if if your odds
if the if the horse was only two to one
that won, you know, I would have lost
money on the race. But you know, that's
that's it reminds me of of the way that
these people run it sometimes like I'm
going to give you a bunch of different
indicators and you know, when it's right
when one is right, I'm going to claim I
predicted it and by using the indicator.
Well, you could see here, you know, I
mean like I said, you know, nothing is
um certain. Nothing is going to be ever
be 100%. We we we all like dealing in in
certainty and
um
you know, no one can guarantee the
correct analysis of the market, you
know, but you know, the the better your
tools are, you know, the better
decisions you're going to make.
And you know, anyone that tries to I see
these Forex guys saying, "Oh, you know,
I got 98% winners. This is me. I'm
carrying a briefcase full of cash." I
mean, you know, first of all, why would
you carry a briefcase full of cash? But
um yeah, it
that's not realistic. Um you know,
trust me. I've I've known
I've known big traders all my life and
you know, they don't walk around with
briefcases full of cash. They do carry
cash. Some of them carry um you know,
nice wads so to speak, but um that's
about it.
So anyway, you know, if you found this
helpful great. If you didn't, you know,
whatever. But um you know, again I do
these presentations to, you know, to
help the people of my software, people
that use my software
um understand how to use it and make
better trading decisions. So you know,
thanks again and I'll talk to you later.
Bye-bye.